hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
simultaneous exhibition that paul morphy
held in paris
and it's uh well it's uh quite the game
he's facing
a gentleman we know absolutely nothing
about and i've tried uh checking some
sources and no one knows
anything about this gentleman so if you
know who this mysterious person might be
mr uh bornemann uh do share in the
in the comment section below so without
further ado let's check it out
uh morphe again with the white pieces i
will some from time to time i'll
mention this when we're covering
simultaneous exhibitions
uh the person who holds the simultaneous
exhibition most of the times uh
has the white pieces on all the boards
and yes i've seen some questions in the
comments uh is morphe actually playing
blindfolded
i don't think he actually had a
blindfold because he was in the other
room and all of the other players the
eight players that he was facing were
in the other room so he didn't have any
sight of the boards so he would just
yell the moves and you know they would
yell some moves back and then morphe
would
uh uh you know uh state which board
which uh move goes to so this is the
fifth game that we're covering
morphe versus bournemouth uh let's check
it out so morphe with the white pieces
opens with e4 with
e5 and now f4 morphe goes for the king's
gambit and bournemouth declines the
gambit by playing bishop to c5
uh so just continuing development we
have knight to f3
now with a double attack on the e5 pawn
and d6 now
uh we have c3 preparing to strike in the
center with d4
and bishop to g for now pinning morphy's
knight we have bishop to c4 and now
knight to f6 uh and here uh morphe grabs
on e5 instead of knight to f6
you might think okay maybe capture now
but not really because then you weaken
the d4 square morphy can just push d4
and he's gonna have a
a really awesome center here you do not
want to allow this
with black so instead of capturing we
have knight to f6
uh black also just continues development
we have f captures on e5 and now
uh bishop captures on f3 first we have
queen captures and only now d
captures on e5 and the material is
perfectly
equal and now d3 by morphe preparing to
develop the
the light square bishop uh sorry the the
dark square bishop uh
and uh black doesn't mind black could
just castle here black could continue
playing on the queen side maybe with
something like a5
but he decides to go nice to c6 he says
there is no rush
let's just uh continue developing and
it's a good thing morphy has
c3 played so this controls any movements
of this knight on c6
and it's interesting it is already as of
move 8 that this position has never been
reached again
so uh bishop to g5 morphe continues
development and
now a6 for the moment the morphe cannot
castle king's side this bishop is
cutting off the diagonal so he's gonna
have to figure out how to
how to go about to this we have knights
to d2 and now
bishop to e7 here uh he says all right
my knight here is pinned i can't really
move it i don't have
any ideas what to do here i'm just gonna
go back then i'm gonna move the knight
and then we're going to trade some
pieces
uh morphe decides to castle queenside
the d3 pawn is nicely defended twice so
you don't have to worry about that and
queen to d7 black now also is ready to
castle both kingside and
queenside uh and now morphy says okay
how do i improve this position
uh well i could push some pawns like i
could maybe push h4 i could capture i
could maybe play king b1 i could play on
the queen side i could do a lot of
things bring the rook into the game
uh but this night is uh well this night
is pretty weird here it's not
on the most optimal square so i'm going
to shift it i'm going to play knight f
1 to e3 and then shift it over to d5 and
it's going to be
a really strong piece there so here
morphe starts with knight to f1
something also
if you're a beginner you should always
look for moves like these to go
back with the knife even though your
first inclination is to go always
forward sometimes
you have to go back first so knight to
f1 and here we have queen side castles
by bernaman
and now knight to e3 morphy just
continues improving the position
and now the problem is uh well the the
f7 pawn is
uh hanging and black needs to do
something about this so black should
either defend it or try something else
and here defending it isn't all that
great here
uh what you should do is actually
knights to a5 i'm just going to show it
because it's very interesting
and now uh capturing an f7 would be it
would be too dangerous
morphe would have to go back or even
just bring the rook into the game allow
this capture knight for bishop
because if you go after the pawn here
then rook h2f8 attacks the bishop
and once the bishop moves and now you
have this very exciting
knight captures on e4 you open up an
attack towards the queen
and once the queen captures the knight
now uh well the bishop here is
undefended so first you're just going to
capture on b3 with
check a captures and now bishop captures
here and black's position is perfectly
fine
if not better so uh knights the a5
definitely
the way to go morphe would not have time
to capture on f7 uh but
black decided to play something else
black played first h6
uh bishop to h for g5 bishop to g3 and
now as the pawn is still hanging now uh
rooked uh rook to f8 or rather not that
rook rook
uh rook d f a and now the rooks aren't
um
placed all that great the this rook on
h8 really not doing all that much in
this rook here
and now if morphe wanted to play
positionally he would simply play knight
f5
get this knight to this beautiful
outpost and those rooks are pretty much
useless for
for a very long time but morphy as usual
finds a quicker way to deal with things
he plays knights to d5
point being that now the knight cannot
be captured or rather capturing the
knight is the best move here but
if you do this and allow pawn captures
then uh the e5 pawn will fall as well
you don't really care about knight a5
just bishop captures
attacks the rook if f6 bishop g3 now
you're up upon and you don't have a
worry in the world and of course if
knight captures the bishop then your
position is just
amazing you're just gonna uh well it's
maybe even something like bishop f2 c uh
c5 c6 completely
bust open uh black's king side and it's
just a great position to play
so instead after knight to d5 uh
bournemouth tried knight to e8 but
this uh simply will not do morphe
immediately strikes in the center
and now there's a double attack on the
pawn but what morphe really wants is to
open up this diagonal for the bishop
so he captures on d4 c captures and now
bishop to d8 even to reinforce the c7
square because morphe is attacking it
twice
uh it was already defended by the queen
bishop and king so maybe this is a bit
of an uh over
this bishop movie is a bit of an
overprotection uh but
okay if borderman decided that wait what
are we to
uh you know do about it so we have rook
h2f1
now threatening to pick up the f7 pawn
and
knight to d6 nicely defending just
bishop b3
a nice calm move from morphe uh we have
knight to b5 now with a double attack on
the d4 pawn and here morphy
uh goes queen to e3 he defends the pawn
although uh there is really no reason to
defend it you could just play some like
king to b1
and this spawn can never be captured i
mean you don't want to open up this
uh this d file so uh morphe okay place
king
queen to e3 and there's still more to be
said about the position for example if
black goes king b8 the game continues
the white is of course
a lot better the uh the center here is
just uh you know uh
spectacular he still has the uh the
bishop paired the rooks are nicely
placed
on on the d and that file so white will
always be better but
uh black can still you know maybe pose
some
problems however here black played f5
which kind of makes sense you want to
attack white strong center with your
flank pawn
but this in this exact position f5 is a
bit
premature and now morphy punishes this
idea by simply capturing it e captures
on f5 and morphe says
i have now a beautiful past f pawn and
there's nothing you can do about it
uh but border man uh says i i do not
agree with that and
here he just captures the pawn uh you
don't have to capture it you could try
something like rook to e8
this was maybe black's best attempt to
go after the queen and after queen d3
now just uh eliminate the d4 pawn and
the game kind of continues with
white having a much better position
however after he captures an f5
rook capture sun f5 was played but now
now feel free to pause the video and
win the game for morphe while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
the free queen and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it is of course knight to b6 with check
and this is just a beautiful move
because the king and queen are now
forked
and of course this is a royal fork black
can simply resign if the knight is not
captured
so c captures on b6 is the only move but
now the other one comes
bishop to e6 now again uh scoring
skewing the queen and also the rook here
on f5 there's nothing
nothing to be done here uh so what
you're going to do you could resign but
of course the bournemouth decided to
play this through as this is his only
game that anyone will ever see as we
don't know who this gentleman is so why
not
you know play a few more moves so rook
to d5 of course
the rook cannot be captured because if
you're capturing something it's gonna be
the queen
uh we have uh uh rook to f7 uh
just uh you know uh increasing the
pressure the
the rook cannot be captured because
because of the pin here so there's
really not much for black to play
97 was played but now morphe is still
not capturing he does
uh what a gentleman would do in a
situation like this he plays king to b1
uh just getting the king away from the c
file rook to c1 is coming and there's no
rush to capture the queen you know
as long as you don't have to capture it
more if you will keep it there
we have rook to e8 now getting some more
defenders into the position but it
doesn't matter rook c1
check this is just beautiful the rook
controls the c file the bishop controls
this diagonal
knight to c7 and now uh that
there's really no way to improve the
position any further now morphy captures
the queen
bishop captures on d7 check rook
captures in the now even d5 opening up
some lines
uh towards the b6 pawn towards the black
king rather
because this knight cannot capture
because well we're just the
the rook is on the c file this knight
cannot capture because you can just pick
up the rook there's also this
the knight is pinned so you cannot
capture the queen and while you could
capture with the rook this is what
morphy actually wants just queen capture
series happening and then everything
will be attacking that c7 square
uh this is just amazing uh so knight the
c6 was played
one last attempt at uh at the trick now
of course the the rook cannot be
captured
because now both of the knights are on c
file so the knight will be able to
capture the queen
but morphy says not a problem uh while i
could play something boring like queen
captures on b6 this is no way for
history to remember you
i'm just gonna offer the queen back so d
captures on c6 and this is actually a
forced win so it doesn't even matter
that morphe is giving back the queen
uh rook captures an e3 now comes c
captures on d7 with
check king to b8 and now uh feel free to
pause the video and
win this game for morphe there a lot of
moves are winning but
only one move wins it the way morphe
wins games so
uh have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
uh yet again uh winning the game in
great style and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course
rook captures on c7 this is what morphe
played and it was in this position i
don't know 32 that
bournemouth resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
uh whatever you play uh you're just a
lost i mean
there's no move you could even play this
is just a terrible position for black
and of course
if the obvious bishop captures and c7 is
played
then just d8 queen and that's it the
black king is in check you cannot
capture due to the pin
you have to move the king not just
characters and now either queen to b8 or
queen captures here will be checkmate
that that's just it so really really a
spectacular game morphe once again
uh i mean uh he plays all of these
masterpieces blindfold against eight
opponents simultaneously and this is
just a very very impressive and the way
he didn't uh
here i mean this is just uh this is the
way you want you know people to remember
you you know
yeah in positions like these when your
opponent even plays something like this
don't
play the boring queen b6 you know offer
the queen back and that's that that's
the good stuff
uh so yeah uh this is the game uh hope
you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank eugene tucker
mr hoody guy john hart uh michael bowers
and conrad bertolt for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and uh we are
uh having a a nice live stream today so
do check that out
if you are able to uh in some maybe two
three hours
uh see you soon